So what if we said hypothetically
something like this.
Let's say that morality
isn't a philosophy.
It's not something explicit,
something implicit.
How does it evolve?
Well,
emotional creatures produce it.
You don't have to produce it in isolation
if you were weren't a social animal.
If you live the solitary and
nocturnal existence by yourself,
there's no need for morality cause you
don't have to regulate your behavior with
regards to your peers,
but your social animals.
So you're stuck with everybody else.
But everybody else could be
conceived of as a grand average.
Right?
How would you act towards
the average person?
Well,
I would say that very,
very stable moral systems tell you
exactly that and they say things like,
uh,
do on others as you would
have them do unto you.
Right?
Basic principle of reciprocity.
Why does that work?
And it's a complex precept.
It means I should treat you like
I would like to be treated by you.
And you might think,
well that means to be nice to you,
but that isn't really what it
means because Nice isn't enough.
Right?
What I want from you
really is communication.
Real communication feedback.
What am I doing that's
acceptable and good?
unacceptable and not good?
And that ladder aspect of feedback
as part of the reason why,
if you're psychopathological and isolated,
you're in much worse shape because half
of your sanity or three quarters of it,
or 90% of it,
who knows is distributed sanity.
You don't have to be that sane as long
as you're hanging around other people.
Because as soon as you do
something that's deviant,
they're going to raise an eyebrow at you,
right?
And then you think,
oh,
well no,
that,
and as soon as you do something good,
then they're going to pay more
attention to you and smile at you.
So all of the information about how to
regulate yourself is out there in the
world,
right?
The average person.
How many people do you
interact with in a week?
300 say maybe it's not that many.
100.
How about any year thousand two thousand
five thousand ten thousand what are
they all telling you?
Well,
the message is similar across people.
How similar.
Don't know exactly how similar.
That's what stories telling you.